Netflix has delivered 13 fresh
steaming-hot cups of Luke Cage and boy
were they worth the wait
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the ending
of Luke Cage season 2 for hidden clues
easter eggs and what it all means for
season 3 obviously spoilers ahead for
the show so take care if you're not
up-to-date or add this to your watch
later playlist at the end of season 2
bushmaster is severely weakened after
Luke's watered his attempt to kill
mariah until the tells him he needs rest
and nightshade he can only get in
Jamaica Mariah's in prison charged with
multiple murders but soon dies at the
hands of her own daughter which means
that shade still to give evidence on
Mariah is no longer valid so he's
arrested for his crimes mariah has set
up Luke for a fool by leaving Harlem's
Paradise to him in her will she thinks
the club and the power that comes with
it will act as a siren song to harlem's
hero corrupting him and everything he
stands for so is she right
well the running theme in season two is
the fine line that separates a hero from
a villain whether that's Luke Cage and
bushmaster or Luke and Mariah and
showrunner Jo hidari Coker has said he
regards the relationship between Mariah
and Lucas very similar to Batman and the
Joker in that they complete each other
one is the reason the other exists a
Mariah more or less tells Luke this in
the finale
you made me find who I really am in a
strange way we're responsible for each
other and there are certainly numerous
moments in the final episode that draw
parallels between the Stokes family and
the path on which Luke now finds himself
for instance we see Luke standing in
front of a portrait of Biggie Smalls
wearing a crown just as cottonmouth did
last season and Mariah does this season
and then there are those images of Luke
standing in front of that round window
looking down on Harlem's paradise like a
king in his castle surveying his domain
watch from above
like a hawk or a dictator we also see
Luke's whispered conversations with his
new crew which includes sugar one of the
Stokes family's men and that moment were
misty is shut out of Luke's new life
after previously working with him for
Harlem clearly and ominously echoes the
end of the Godfather also shut out by
Luke is Claire who Luke says should go
home when sugar tells him she's arrived
at the club this feels in stark contrast
to how Luke defended Claire against
Mariah at the start of the season
Rosario Dawson's not sure if she'll be
in any more Marvel series after this so
it seems like the show's creating an
option for her not to return while also
alienating Luke from all his old friends
we also see Harlem's hero meet with
other crime bosses like Rosalie Carbone
as mariah did at the auction
geographically Luke is still in Harlem
but symbolically he's a long way from
his former home at the barber shop
now that DW has kicked him out for
becoming a crime boss a Luke Colleoni
and a Luke Trump as he calls him
DW wants a shop to return to the neutral
state as it had before tone murdered pop
there in season one according to
showrunner Jo hidari coca by DW calling
Luke Trump he's basically saying you're
deluded if you think the way you're
doing things is going to change things
for the better and Coca has also
compared Luke's path this season to the
Shadowland storyline in the comics where
daredevil takes over the hand however
there are still signs that Luke
certainly intends for things to be
different with him in charge compared to
the Stokes the portrait of Biggie is
taken down from the wall and replaced
with one of Muhammad Ali which itself is
reminiscent of images was seen of Luke
throughout the series however the way
cottonmouths biggie portrayed has
swapped out here reminds me of the end
of season one where mariah did the same
replacing it with her Basquiat painting
Luke may momentarily stand in front of
Biggie's crown but he's adamant that
he's not the king but rather the sheriff
or diplomat of Harlem
so maybe Luke will prove Mariah season
two schemes against him and cost a mouse
everybody wants to be a king speech
wrong
likewise when DW accused Luke of taking
on the role of a king Luke replied using
a chess analogy I thought you weren't a
king rook
wait
do this you don't have to do it like
this
somebody hosting that's interesting
because this idea of Luke being a castle
rule that protects Harlem picks up on
similar imagery that Mariah used to
describe herself as a protector of
Harlem to the judge in Mariah's mind the
Stokes showed up the wall around the
neighborhood in other words by
protecting their own criminal empire
they also protected others around them
with Mariah out of the game and crime
rounded again Luke believed he can try
and plug the holes in the wall himself
Luke's new clothes may be more formal
than usual akin to cottonmouth a Mariah
but they still have a golden tinge to
them a sign that underneath this is
still the yellow t-shirt and hoodie
wearing hero we've met over the last two
seasons as Comanche said earlier this
season even if you put it in a
three-piece suit street still Street so
while the show certainly draws parallels
between Luke and Mariah the Godfather
and the current yes president I don't
think we'll see Luke go fully or
irredeemably Stokes coolly ownio Trump
in season three more likely we'll see
him Teeter on the edge and maybe fool
over for a while as he struggles to
maintain his integrity his identity as a
hero and also his temper as we saw
happen at color's apartment early on in
the season and of course it's important
to remember the words of Luke's dad at
the very end of season two which for me
had vibes of Uncle Ben's with great
power comes great responsibility speech
that kind of power comes its share of
pain what comes out when that pressure
is heaviest that's the real magic that's
what defines your man that's what
defines being a human so expect the
pressure on Luke to increase in season
three one of those pressure points will
likely be Tilda Johnson who's rather
obviously annoyed that after all her
mother's talk of family first always
Mariah's will only gives her Cornell's
keyboard while leaving Harlem's Paradise
to Luke tilde's character in the show
where she's annalistic doctor and
Mariah's estranged daughter is rather
different from her comic book origins
where Tilda Johnson
nightshade is a genius criminal
scientist with the pancha for turning
people into werewolves and using robots
to run Harlem yet despite those
differences the show includes numerous
hints - TV Tilda's comic book
counterpart including her intelligence
her scientific background and how she
uses nightshade to help bush master and
the best of the Latonya or spiders kiss
which tilde uses to poison her mother in
prison is likely a hat tip to the Spider
Island storyline the comics were
nightshade gained spider powers and when
she arrives at Harlem's paradise after
Luke's taken it over Tilda's look is a
clear nod to the design of her
villainous character in the comics all
of these comic book callbacks as well as
Tilda's anger over the will and the fact
that she used her herbal knowledge both
to aid bushmaster and to murder her
mother indicate that will see tilde
return in season 3 where she could well
be set up as an antagonist to Luke
another pressure point on Luke in season
3 will be criminal underworld boss
Rosalie Carbone as she tells Luke she
has Russian crime syndicates on her side
as well so he better tread very
carefully in his future dealings with
her
and while Carbone agrees to wolof
Haarlem against the current crime wave
she doesn't see this as a long-term
thing mark box around Hana
how much would it cost to get a key made
I can't be bought you can't answer that
truthfully yet sweetheart you don't know
your price yet and at the end of episode
13 is a potentially ominous moment when
after the rapper Rakim says you pay with
your life in the Kings paradise the
camera cuts to Carbone in the comics
Rosalie is part of the carbone crime
family and falls for Frank Castle aka
The Punisher until she realizes who he
is after which she puts out a hit on him
I don't think we'll see Castle turn up
in Luke Cage next season but what we
could see is Luke taking on a similar
role to him with Carbone putting the
moves on Luke especially given how she
ends their meeting next time let's do
this over coffee
I don't like espresso no one's made you
a proper cup still the next time we see
Carbone will actually be in season 3 of
daredevil so obviously whatever happens
with her in that show could well affect
her future in this series now what did
you think of season 2 of Luke Cage and
what would you like to see
and next let's continue the conversation
in the comments below
tap left to check out my TV and movies
explained playlists including Jurassic
world 2 and tap right for my marble
playlist including Avengers and ant-man
and the wasp if you enjoyed this video a
thumbs up is always appreciated thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers